I want to look at the economy and our
own happiness and the environment as
competing points is a no-no and while
the going was good a lot of business was
looking at it that way that they could
make her part and it didn't matter that
the environment was being destroyed and
it's only after this downturn that
people are even asking especially I just
open world is asking this question I
agree with all of this that it has to be
something that goes side by side and not
something that is if this wins this
loses because it can take however much
money you are listed in the Midas touch
bit that you touch the face of earth and
it isn't addressed and yes more action
is required upon all of us maybe drop of
water we save every tree we don't break
down is going to make a difference so
let's make it now today and every movie